the first thing I look for when I'm
looking for a job or hopefully you know
I get offered one but I look at the
script the script is the first thing the
written word the the the characters if
it's story is character driven or or I
look for strong female characters
obviously although I have played a man
before in fact my first role was playing
Noah Claypool The Undertaker's son in
Oliver so yeah I played a lot of
different characters but I always look
for the the script to move me and
characters who have a nice arc they have
a beginning middle and end they go
through something they come out the
other side they don't always have to be
you know good characters they can be
evil you know whatever I just if I can
find a way to relate to them and see
myself doing I get excited writing the I
get excited reading the script if it
resonates with me I jump at it well this
is going to be an odd reference because
I don't know if everyone's seen this
movie but I did this movie called
drop-dead gorgeous a long time ago and
when I read that script I knew I wanted
to play the role was a trailer trash
woman named Loretta and I just thought
the script was enormous Lee fun and I
loved what she the character got to to
do and I had to fight for that part I
the producers producer didn't want me
the director wanted me for it and I just
remember that was the first time I I
wanted something that I went after and
it is a comedy it was a mockumentary
then you know reading the part of CJ
Cregg in the West Wing I read that and
just thought I mean Aaron Sorkin is one
of the greatest writers we have in
America and he wrote a brilliant script
wrote a great character who became one
of my favorite parts I've ever played
because of how she's a role model for
for a lot of women it's a strong woman
role in a in a
male-dominated arena we know Washington
politics and that was a pretty great
part when I read that I was like let me
I always play I seem to play the the
women who are who hold things together
everything's falling apart around them
and they they are the glue and they hold
things together and I don't know if
that's because I'm tall or I'm kind of I
don't know I look like I know what I'm
doing which is not what's really going
on I'm an actor I like things that are
messy I don't necessarily when I'm doing
something that's a comedy I'm not I
don't act like I'm in a comedy I don't
try to be funny I think the stakes tend
to be higher when you're in a comedy but
I I kind of look at it as the same even
though I know they're different styles
like doing an old coward play is
different than doing an Arthur Miller
play and I've had the gotten to do both
of those and I know how to operate in
both those worlds and I don't know why I
know how to do that I just do and I
don't know if I learned that or if it's
just instinctual but I I I grew up
watching Carol Burnett on television
watching that great comedian she
inspired me enormous ly and I'm watching
women like you know Maggie Smith and
Judi Dench and and Meryl Streep and all
of these women inspired me as an actress
wanting to be when Laurie Metcalf
inspired me after I saw her in a
performance of balm in Gilead in New
York City and I I wanted to quit acting
after I saw her because I was just I
thought well she's that's it I don't
know if I could do that she's so
brilliant I you know every time I
I start a new project I think how do how
do I do this I don't know how do I feel
like I've forgotten how to act or what I
do in every every single part I think
that and I go what it how do I do this
again and I go back to all my acting
books I go back to my Stanislavski book
I go back to you know David Mamet
actress on acting I go go to I just
start looking at all my acting
books and and and I've even hired acting
coaches just to look at something from a
fresh pair of eyes and get some feedback
and some help but but usually I read I I
read the script or whatever I'm doing a
you know minimum of like ten times just
read it without making any decisions
just read it just to let it get in in my
body and and and and understand the
story and I start to understand what my
character wants and I started out to
figure out what they need and what why
is this scene in the play or movie what
what's important what's what do I have
to accomplish in the scene why is this
scene in this movie why is this scene in
this play what do I need to get and my
objective I think of you know I I Tonya
I play a woman who's on the page pretty
awful horrible abusive woman and my
challenge there is to find her humanity
what makes her three-dimensional because
she's not just a terrible woman there's
something that makes her that she had to
come from you know if she was a little
girl once and had a family so I have to
start putting together that puzzle in my
mind what what she must have been abused
herself this must have happened and and
so it makes sense so I can connect and
have some empathy for her or feel you
know so you know I can play her and and
she's a real human and a real person no
matter how awful
conversely if someone is you know seeing
my character and the way way back was
you know pretty boisterous and loud and
funny and drinking and laughing but but
I knew I had to think okay she's hiding
something there I had to look underneath
all ways looking for what's underneath
that's my favorite thing to do as an
actor I feel like I'm a little detective
trying to figure out what's underneath
the character what makes them what are
they afraid of what do they tell
themselves to get up every day and what
are they but do they believe in and
that's that's the fun work and then and
then I use a lot of music and my acting
I love to prepare listening to if
there's an emotional need I like to
listen to music that moves me and I
studied at the Neighborhood Playhouse in
in New York City and
and they taught you a lot about
emotional preparation and sometimes you
know your preparation doesn't have to
sometimes what for me my preparation has
nothing to do with the character or the
play or the movie or whatever I'm
working on it can have absolutely
nothing to do with it and if the subject
matter itself doesn't I can't connect to
it then I go to music and find what
moves me and I bring that I prepare
forget about it and go and and do the
scene all different ways I and I'm
always looking for help from anyone I'm
always like to tell me how you would do
this how I ask everybody I'm not afraid
to say I don't know how to play this how
would you play this I would ask a
million questions I love the costume
designers to tell they they put me in a
costume and I go oh I think I know who I
am now I'd love to get input from
absolutely everybody
I mean I've definitely always will have
a strong sense of what I'm doing but I
like to hear
don't get me wrong I don't know I don't
like anyone to say you're not doing that
right how to do it better but I I like I
I love to I just emit detective that's
how I think of myself and I like to ask
people what they think of what's going
on for you here what do you think of
what do you think our relationship is
what do you think you know it's fun to
explore those things with your fellow
actors and I think of acting as such a
team sport really I love that I grew up
in the theater and I know what it means
to be on stage and give someone their
moment and then take your moment and
it's very it's like that part of it and
sometimes film actors who actresses
webmin studying in the theater aren't
aware of that part of acting and I feel
sorry for them because it's so much fun
to be onstage with people who know how
to act and give each other moments and
you know people that are generous and
giving with their acting I think the
biggest challenge for me has been my
height I'm six feet tall
also my self-esteem my
feeling that I was ready for something
or wanting to take on the challenge
being intimidated by the whole business
of acting I wish I had actually I mean I
studied the neighborhood play us and I
also went to the Royal Academy of
Dramatic Arts for a I got a fellowship
to study there and I loved all that I
just didn't know how to the business
side of it such a huge part and can be
very intimidating to an actor and I wish
I'd gotten sort of schooled on on that
how to be how to mmm
what the business is what it means how
how does it how do I fit into the
business part of it it's a it's a whole
different animal and the acting is one
side and then the business is some
different and being as an actor you have
to be I'm very thin-skinned and I got
it's it's it's that was challenging
going through auditioning and not
getting things and being told I was too
tall to act being told I was you know
not I was not pretty enough not that you
know those things are really hard to to
go through as a young actor so and yeah
so my own mind getting in my way of
thinking being afraid of I remember I
got my first Broadway play when I was 38
it was a present laughter no cowards
present laughter and I was I was I've
never been so afraid when I my brother
helped me out realising that he made me
realise that that I know that I know
what I'm doing I have the experience
I've grown up doing plays and just
because it's on Broadway doesn't mean
it's the same thing it's the same
relationship to the audience and you'll
be fine he and he helped me through that
but my gosh my getting out of my own way
really was
look biggest challenge it still is but
I'm working on it
every part I have is a challenge
everyone nothing I do is ever like oh I
got this it's easy
I always think oh my god what if I fail
am I going to am I going to and you just
have to put yourself out there and I and
and trust trust yourself and Trust the
people that you work with and you know
every every everything has it's every
part has its challenge I've been lucky
to have two long-running show
on television the west wing and now mom
and it's rare that an actor gets to play
a character over and over like that for
years I did CJ for seven years and it
does get easier you do know I felt very
comfortable in her skin sometimes I felt
a little too comfortable and I got a
little lazy and we'd get into you know
shooting two or three episodes at the
same time doing reshoots and things and
I would literally just be memorizing
lines and you know saying them in rule
and just trusting the fact that I I know
this character I don't have to work
anymore I just have to learn the line
lines and spit him out on the right or
her oh my god it was Jo is really
challenging but so fun to get
comfortable in a character like that and
explore all different aspects of them
through the years and it's it's so it's
a really great opportunity that not too
many actors get to do it so it's a lot
of fun and it's you know it's different
than doing a play over the you know it's
like doing a play I always think of this
like Groundhog Day where you just keep
doing it and I keep thinking if I just
get it right this time I'm not I don't
have to do it again it's kind of fun to
approach doing a play like that but with
the with the TV show and doing recurring
a series um you get a different new
script every time but same character
it's its enormous ly fun I think the
best advice that I could give someone
who was starting out is to to study and
and learn don't be afraid to take
different kinds of classes different
different acting techniques you never
know what's going to work for you and I
found it enormous ly helpful and also
comforting as I was trying to find work
to always be in a class so I was always
acting with people and being around
people who were struggling and doing the
same thing I was that's what saved me I
think when I was and wasn't working as
constantly taking classes getting
involved in theatre companies doing I
did you know backstage work I was a
stagehand for a while I did you know
learning all the different aspects to I
love and you
for directors young directors and
playwrights did they should all take
acting classes they shall know how to
act it's it's very it's a great skill to
have to when you're you know trying to
communicate to actors to know what they
have to go through and you know maybe I
should have taken a director's course I
don't know I would I would be a lousy
director but um I didn't do that for my
but I did you know I haven't been the
theater I did a lot of backstage work
and build sets and you know cold shows
and ran a lighting board ran a sound
board ran you know you just have it
makes you have a lot of appreciation and
respect for everybody in that you work
with and I think that's a great thing to
have to bring to the table
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]